we are so fortunate tonight to have
Charles Murray as our speaker he is a
political scientist author and
libertarian he first came to national
attention in 1984 with the very popular
publication of losing ground which has
been credited as the intellectual
foundation for the welfare reform Act of
1996 he has written several bestsellers
including his most recent book coming
apart which describes an unprecedented
divergence in American classes over the
last half-century he served as a
panelist at our Atlanta free market
forum in 2011 and his presentation at
the forum at that time is in one of our
in Primus issues and you may pick one of
those up out of the literature tables in
the foyer dr. Murray has a BA in history
from Harvard and a PhD in political
science from MIT would you join me in
welcoming please dr. Charles Murray
thanks very much it's not just the
Atlanta forum that is my history with
Hillsdale I've been speaking at
Hillsdale on and off I guess now since a
few years after losing ground came out
plus some off-site events as well and
it's always a great pleasure to be back
I want to start by making a request of
the audience especially since there are
so many professors in the audience
during the course of my presentation
occasionally you will have come into
your head the thought what are the
policy implications of what he is saying
I want you to suppress that thought
there are no policy implications to what
I'm going to say tonight I know that's a
heretical statement because we are
supposed to always have solutions to
problems and if I were made czar of the
United States I could then impose some
libertarian solutions which I think
would make a difference but that's not
going to happen we do not have a
situation in which any politically
feasible legislation is going to make
much difference to the problems I'm
going to talk about the solutions if
there are ones are going to have to be
cultural and because of that it's
probably best just to concentrate on the
description of the problem I'm talking
about and we can get to solutions at a
later date the the thesis of coming
apart is very simple that we have seen
over the last half-century the emergence
of classes in this country that are
different in kind from anything we have
known before we have always had rich
people and poor people that's not new
they have always lived in somewhat
different parts of town they've had
somewhat different habits and mores but
one of the characteristics of the United
States that made it exceptional was this
very strong sense of visceral sense
among Americans that we were all
Americans together Tocqueville in
writing in the 1830s has a wonderful
paragraph where he talks about
out the opulent members of society take
great care not to separate themselves
from the lower classes they talk to them
every day it is reflected in public
opinion polls within the United States
who are people who obviously are not
middle class they're much richer and
better educated and more powerful than
that say oh yeah I'm just middle-class
it is manifest as been manifested
historically in the great pride that the
most successful members of society took
in being members of the fraternal
organizations that drew their membership
across social classes and as I look
around the audience here where there's
an age demographic not that different
from mine um I think a lot of you know
what such phrases as getting too big for
your britches means that there are lots
of ways in which even though there was
economic inequality and different
classes that you were an American in
some fundamental way that transcended
that and what I'm saying tonight is
that's going not going all together it's
going in the book I spend a considerable
amount of time describing the formation
of a new lower class and the formation
of a new upper class this is not going
to be a full-scale lecture tonight and
so I'm going to cut some corners I'm
going to skip lightly over the formation
of the new lower class and concentrate
on the formation of the new upper class
because let's face it a lot of the
issues associated with the new upper
class are ones which are relevant to
people in this room and especially to
our children but start with the new
lower class I'm going to give you some
statistics not a whole lot but some and
they are going to be quite limited I'm
going to be talking about non Latino
whites between the ages of 30 and 49 why
am i doing that because it gets rid of a
whole lot of baggage so that if I'm
talking about numbers which talk about
problems it is completely natural for
someone to say well to what extent are
these
problems associated with the black
community or the Latino community or
some minority to what extent of these
national problems when you're talking
about non Latino of whites ages 30 to 49
you're talking about people in the prime
of life who don't have any good excuses
all right let's start out with marriage
marriage is probably the most
fundamental social institution there is
it has collateral effects that go deep
into all kinds of cultural phenomena
it used to be virtually universal as of
1960 ages 30 to 49 non non Latino of
whites those in the upper middle class
defined as people with college education
and working in the professions or in a
managerial position we're married at the
rate of 94 percent that's about as close
to total participation as you can have
in any social institution but if you
take the white working-class with
working-class defined as a high school
education working on a blue-collar or a
low level service job 84% were married
not quite as high but it was the
overwhelming norm by which working-class
communities were organized skip ahead 50
years to 2010 you've heard all the
stories about the decline of marriage
the rise the divorce the rise of out of
wedlock births and all the rest of it in
the white upper-middle class 84 percent
were married as of 2010 there had been a
reduction but most of that had occurred
in the 60s and 70s that number has been
stable since the 1980s and furthermore
divorce has been going down so that 84
percent represents a whole lot of first
and only marriages marriage is alive and
well in the upper middle class white
working-class 2010 48% married from 84
percent to 48% in 50 years is a
phenomenally rapid change in a
fundamental social institution why is
that important well a whole lot of
reasons one of them has to do with
social
the social capital referring to all the
ways in which communities work whether
it's parents trying to get a four-way
stop sign near where their kids are
playing or attending PTA meetings or
coaching Little League teams or
participating in fun drives and all the
rest of that it's married couples who do
that unmarried dads do not coach Little
League teams unmarried moms don't
pretend PTA meetings at nearly the rate
that married moms do if for no other
reason they don't have the time social
capital is radically diminished when you
have a road it could decline in marriage
and social capital that makes
communities work the effects on male
performance in the labor force is huge
when marriage goes down one of the
triumphs of modern social science is
that after a great deal of statistical
analysis it has been determined that
marriage civil eise's men this is a big
surprise there's there's a thing called
the marriage premium the marriage
premium whereby men who are married get
much more productive the social apps
there is the economist have been arguing
about this you know what does this mean
is this you know as a complex cause
what's an effect and so for this a lot
come on guys get married they settle
down they get focused they go to work
but they aren't married they aren't that
way who did not know that except except
academics but the fact is the fact is
that along with the decline in marriage
in the working class here's what's
happened to male labor force
participation labor force participation
means either you have a job or you were
looking for a job and as of 1960 if you
were a male ages 30 to 49 and you were
not working or looking for a job you
were a bum you were a bum according to
your girlfriend according to your
parents according to your neighbors
everybody thought you were and they were
not shy about letting you know that and
guess what as result unless you were
paraplegic you were in the labor force
1960
to 2008 this time not 2010 because I
want to get a number that comes before
the recession set in so in 2008 among
white males ages 30 to 49
one out of eight was not even in the
labor force and if you think that's a
function of G there are no good
unionized jobs anymore there the you
know the economy is terrible
we had a natural experience in the
experiment in the last half of the 1990s
whereby there was a period of about four
or five years when you could get jobs
way above the minimum wage for as many
hours as you wanted to work easily and
white males did not come flocking back
into the labor force then this rise has
been gradually referee flex a cultural
change in the attitude toward work that
is profoundly troubling I could go on at
more length but what I'm really saying
and because I do want to shift to the
new upper class is that there has been a
kind of cultural change within the
working class which has led large
numbers of people to drop out they no
longer participate in the institutions
of American life in the way that they
formerly did and the kind of glue that
has held us together as a society as
weakened accordingly okay let's talk
about the new upper class don't confuse
this with the upper-middle class now I'm
talking about the elites it's not the
nut 1% versus the 99 percent I'm not
talking about income inequality I'm
talking about the people who run the
country and I run the country I mean yes
politically but I also mean run the
economy and run the culture so the new
upper class includes the senior
government officials in Washington yes
it also includes the most influential
people in the financial world in New
York City it includes the people who run
the major media outlets in New York and
Washington DC news outlets it includes
the people who write for sitcoms
who produce the content of the
entertainment media and it includes
people in Silicon Valley as well these
are the folks whose behavior and actions
and the rest of it do things to the
culture that shape it it's a it's a
pretty small group probably if you're
thinking about the narrow elite the
people who have national influence it's
probably not even a hundred thousand
people you can also talk about a broader
elite of which many of you are members
of which which is the people who are
influential in the culture politics in
the economy of the cities in which you
live over the last 50 years we have seen
a separation of that group from the rest
of society as well it has been driven by
a couple of phenomena that are good in
themselves but that had collateral
effects there were two of them first
over the course of the 20th century
brains became worth a whole lot more
money in the marketplace just plain old
raw intellectual power and to illustrate
that let me give you example I'm going
to be describing a person that almost
all of you have met this is a person
with terrific math ability are terrific
visual spatial skills who you would not
trust to go across the street and buy
you a loaf of bread and and who has no
interpersonal skills whatsoever what
could that person do in 1920 be an
actuary you know you couldn't even be a
math professor very easily if he had no
interpersonal skills whatsoever
what can a person with precisely that
same skillset do today he can juggle
competing six-figure offers from firms
in Silicon Valley for his programming
talents because the talents I've just
described are very important and
becoming a brilliant programmer if he's
really a terrific pure mathematician he
can be juggling offers from the quant
funds in New York City that can offer
him dreams beyond the wildest dreams of
avarice and wealth beyond the wildest
dreams of avarice
but it's not just those peculiar kinds
of skills that have become more valuable
in the marketplace think about for
example an attorney if it's nineteen
twenty and you're an attorney you are
probably one of the more of affluent
people in town you make a good income
but you aren't really rich because the
kinds of money you get paid if you're an
attorney in 1920 are the kinds of fees
that private people having legal issues
can afford to pay of what kind of money
can you make if you are a brilliant
attorney today if you can negotiate a
favorable ruling by a regulatory agency
in Washington that affects a
corporation's bottom line by a billion
dollars you are worth four figures an
hour easy if you can negotiate these
incredibly complex international mergers
of corporations you can be worth a
commission of a couple of million
dollars and and it's it's not just being
a lawyer and having a law degree it's
having the intellectual ability to do
these complex things same things happen
throughout the economy what are you
worth if you are Don Draper for those of
you who watch Mad Men if you are Don
Draper and you have a track record of
being able to increase through your
advertising campaign the market share of
your client by one percent well if your
client has annual sales of twenty
million dollars you're worth one amount
if your client has annual sales of
twenty billion dollars you are worth a
whole lot more
okay this is fine you are getting paid
for real contributions that are worth
that in the marketplace but now can join
that with a second trend that went on in
the twentieth century again a good thing
which is that we got a whole lot better
at taking the very smartest kids
wherever they came from whatever the
background was and shipping them off to
the best colleges it happened
during the 1950's that was really the
critical decade it continued into the
60s and 70s but I'll give you an example
my alma mater is Harvard University in
1952
the mean SAT score verbal of entering
Harvard freshman was 583 if you have a
child with an SAT verbal score of 583 I
do not recommend that he apply to
Harvard oh that's not even in the
ballpark by 1960 which was just eight
years later that mean SAT verbal score
was about 680 the average Harvard
freshman in 1952 would have been in the
bottom 10% of the class by 1960 that
same phenomenon went on throughout the
educational system as colleges
throughout the country B can't be beaten
so there was a cognitive stratification
that went on this is part of the
American dream that if you have talent
in this country and can work hard or
willing to work hard you will get a
chance to realize that but there were
side effects you were bringing together
on college campuses a whole lot of
really smart kids who were then going
out into the world and making a whole
lot of money because of the increased
value of brains the socialization that
goes on in that kind of situation with
that kind of homogeneity a background is
way different from the kind of
socialization of the upper classes
before here's an example in 1960 there
were already neighborhoods in this
country which were very well known as
the place that the powerful rich people
lived Upper East Side of New York lower
Westchester County North Shore Chicago
Beverly Hills and Bel Air Burlingame
mountains south of San Francisco those
kinds of places
I collected data on 14 of those rich and
famous and powerful towns of using 1960
census data and I calculate
two numbers one was the median family
income and the other was the percentage
of adults with college degrees I want to
know what the median family income on
the Upper East Side of New York was in
1960 answer $55,000 that's expressed in
2010 dollars that's not affluence that
doesn't mean that there were not rich
people living in the Upper East Side
they were there were very small minority
of the total people living there overall
with the 14 neighborhoods I chose in
1960 the median family income was I
think $64,000 over all of them and the
median percentage of people with college
degrees was 26 percent now that ladder
that ladder statistic means what was the
typical a couple married couple living
in Scarsdale living in Winnetka Illinois
it was probably the guy had a college
degree
probably just a BA and the wife had a
high school diploma that was normal and
with in Winnetka or with in West Arsdale
you had a whole lot of people who
weren't rich and well-educated at all
you had a great deal of heterogeneity
you go back to those same 14
neighborhoods as of the 2000 census the
median family income was up to 164
thousand dollars in constant dollars and
you've now had about 76% with college
degrees but much more than that a whole
lot of those were not only both members
of the couple with college degrees but
both with advanced degrees and a great
many of them coming from the elite
colleges the result of that has been
some bubbles that have formed and the
biggest bubbles had been formed in those
parts of the country where the most
powerful people live in Northwest
Washington DC those of you who know
Washington DC know the following that if
you hold power in Washington DC you live
in Northwest Washington or the adjacent
suburbs of Maryland and Virginia it's
it's basically about 13 zip codes
that form the place where almost
everybody who's a mover and shaker in
Washington lives I calculated an index
combining education and income and
ranked every ZIP code in the country on
that index out of the 13 zip codes which
hold most of these people 11 were not
just in the 99th percentile 11 of the 13
were in the top half of the 99th
percentile and the other two were in the
98th percentile and the lower half of
the 1999 percentile over all around
Washington DC you now have contiguous
zip codes of more than a million people
that are in the top five percentiles on
this index of education and wealth what
that means is that you have the next
generation growing up in a bubble in
which they can live without ever coming
into contact with the real America and
the same thing is true of New York city
of Los Angeles California and Silicon
Valley what does this mean well this is
where I think a lot of people in the
room know exactly what I'm going to talk
about which is that it's one thing to
have become successful in life if you've
grown up in a working-class or
middle-class neighborhood you remember
what it was like it's another thing to
have grown up going k-12 schools either
private or really good public schools in
which the dumbest kid in the class is
probably at the 70th percentile of the
national distribution of IQ you go from
those to a nice college sometimes a
selective college often an elite college
you spend your summers with internships
at places like AEI or Brookings or
others where you were again surrounded
by people just like you and you go from
there to graduate school or law school
where you move seamlessly into a good
career
and you never come in contact with
anybody else as I wrote the book I was
trying to figure out a way to get my
readers to realize how isolated they
were and so I created a quiz has 25
items you've got a maximum of 100 points
and I and I said to myself well I want
my readers to prove to themselves that
what I'm saying is correct now some of
the questions in the quiz were good
social science questions such as have
you ever lived for at least a year in
the course of your life in a
neighborhood in which fewer than half of
the people had college degrees have you
ever lived for at least a year in a
neighborhood
below the poverty line so forth some of
my other questions were a little
mischievous have you or your spouse ever
purchased a pickup truck
have you or your spouse ever stocked the
fridge with a mass-market American beer
I asked that question because the new
upper-class despises Bud and Coors and
Miller and light don't even ask about
Light Miller life you know their beers
are a perfect shade of deep amber made
by Belgian elves and they will talk
about these at at great length too if I
had to say to myself one of the most
important questions in the quiz one of
them was have you ever walked on a
factory floor I didn't even say worked
I said walked everything that we wear
everything that we use is made in a
factory what does it say about what you
know about the world if you've never
even seen what a factory for looks like
and the other question I think is
crucially important is have you ever
held a job that caused a body part to
hurt at the end of the day carpal tunnel
syndrome does not count if you have
never held such a job it is
fundamentally impossible for you to
empathize with the very large number of
people who hold that kind of job every
day you have no idea what it's like well
III think that the quiz accomplished its
purpose it was actually put up I did a
segment for the NewsHour on public
television and they put it up in their
website and more than a quarter of a
million people have taken the test and
and I have also found at AEI when I
tried out the tests on the younger
members of AEI
I was really happy to hear that people
who got high scores which means they
weren't in a bubble were high-fiving
each other and people who got low scores
were unhappy somebody pointed out to me
that that I might be jumping to
conclusions here because kids at AEI
want to get a high score on a test no
matter what the test is South
but but I think the point may have
gotten across to them but that doesn't
put aside a real problem that we have as
a society which is increasingly the
people who run the country haven't a
clue about how ordinary America works
and there's an asymmetry here if a truck
driver does not empathize with the
priorities of a cabinet secretary that's
not too important because the truck
driver cannot mess up the cabinet
Secretary's life
the cabinet secretary can mess up the
truck drivers life by not understanding
what his priorities are furthermore
another kind of problem has infected the
new upper class which makes me worry
about the future even more historically
and I'm drawing an on Arnold Toynbee for
this historically cultures have been led
by a confident elite confident in their
own values willing to express those
values proclaim those values as being
the right way to live and the rest of
society has followed along and I think
that Toynbee was right in saying this
has been a characteristic of vibrant
growing civilizations that stopped in
the United States among the new upper
class that I'm talking about the
reigning value now is non-judgmental ISM
so that well yes I'm married yes we had
our children within wedlock yes we do
ABC other kinds of things but who are we
to say that other people should do the
same thing the new upper class will not
preach what it practices now I use that
phrase in the book and I've caught a lot
of flack because I think people have the
sense I want them to go down to a street
corner in a working-class neighborhood
with a bullhorn and that's not really
what I'm talking about
I'm saying I want it to be in the air
that certain kinds of standards of
virtues are a good way to live
a way that has worked for the people who
practice them and that also have a moral
foundation that they they think is
worthy of of allegiance and that kind of
conversation has almost disappeared now
I can't stop without saying all right
what do we do next as I said at the
beginning public policy does not have
any answers for us here is a truth
however about American societies history
which is we have had cultural Great
Awakenings and they have occurred very
rapidly they have that the main ones we
know about are the religious Great
Awakenings there are three or four of
them depending on which historian you're
reading but but those religious Great
Awakenings had enormous impact on
subsequent American history the first
Great Awakening in the 1730's and 40s
shaped the revolutionary generation the
Second Great Awakening in the 1820s
shaped abolitionism shaped all sorts of
other kinds of educational trends also
cut the alcohol consumption of Americans
by some incredible amount the third sort
of Great Awakening in the 1870s and 80s
was the so the precursor of the
Progressive Era they these Great
Awakenings have occurred unplanned of
spontaneously they've had enormous
impact the reaction I have gotten to the
kinds of things I've been saying tonight
suggests to me that in many ways I am
saying things that people in my
audiences have already been thinking
about and that there is a latent
responsiveness to the kinds of cultural
resuscitation that we need that does not
let me tell you exactly how it's going
to occur I'm only saying that it is not
completely unreasonable to hope for it I
guess the message of the book is not
about what we do wholesale it's what we
do retail and buy retail
mean that each of us as parents think
about the way we live our lives you know
do we want to isolate our children from
the great diversity of Americans out
there do we want to live in isolated
enclaves filled with people just like
ourselves is that good for our kids the
question I ask often times is think and
I'm speak when I'm speaking to an
audience that's adult think of the
things that have made you successful in
your life to what extent are you
systematically depriving your children
of those same opportunities insofar as I
got a good response to that and I do get
a good response I think there is hope
the alternative is that the United
States will continue to be successful
economically we will continue to be
powerful internationally but we will
have lost those things that have made
this country exceptional a civic culture
a way of living together that has been
unique among the nations of the earth
and immeasurably precious thank you very
much
we have we have questions and and by the
way Anita at some point I'm going to
rely on you to say we have time for one
more question because I lose track of
time
okay no gate yes sir and we'll have a
mic coming down it's coming down the
aisle right now okay under there I lived
in a small town I say small town that
probably not so small it was a form four
miles from New York City Teaneck and I
think it was a very integrated and it
was integrated because of the school
system it had seven grammar schools but
it had one high school where all the
grammar schools came together now the
individual grammar schools had different
economical situations but we were all
blended blended together in one high
school and I think that was part of the
success of our country where there was a
school system that blended our younger
people together I wonder what you have
to say to that well I had exactly the
same experience you had we had separate
great schools where I grew up but we had
one high school sir what I what I've
been trying to say to parents about this
is you are way over estimating the
importance of k-12 education for your
kids in terms of how much they learn as
long as they're going to a reasonably
okay school I went to Harvard from
Newton Iowa and Newton Iowa schools
weren't particularly good was I behind
the kids from Exeter and handover when I
got there sure I was but what Harvard
said and was true is these kids from
these mediocre public schools catch up
in about a year and also I went to
Harvard
absolutely ecstatic and excited about
what I was doing whereas the kids from
Exeter and Andover were pretty jaded the
the lesson here is it's I think and I've
acted on this in my own life I think
it's much more important for your
children to be raised among a widely
diverse set of people and having to have
to cope with all of the the range of
situations that presents than it is that
you maximize the amount learned per hour
spent in school and if you take my
advice not only do I think your children
will turn out better you're going to
save about 30 grand a year so right here
sir and then I'll go back towards the
back there
it's a privilege to get to as speakers
here after I put your book down I
couldn't help but wonder what's going to
happen to us and my question is is it
reasonable to think what this kind of
demographic that we can make the system
that we know and love continue to work
like picture in my mind's eye Madison
and Hamlin talking in Madison says these
guys are pretty flaky Alex do you really
think they can make the system work how
about it well I would start out by
blaming Alexander Hamilton for a lot of
our problems
he since the Supreme Court in 1937 said
Hamilton was right and Madison was wrong
and a very important decision well I
will refer to my next book that one I'm
working on right now which is and I
think that limited government a
constitutional limit government is dead
that it's not going to be resuscitated
because we get two or three more
conservative justices in the Supreme
Court it's not going to be resuscitated
because we we win both houses of
Congress and win the presidency I think
that there are systemic things in the
regulatory state which means that you
cannot reverse that through the
political process however and I'm just
going to give this as a teaser all right
number one I think the openings for
federalism are really growing that there
are all sorts of ways in which this
people in different states are saying
actually we want to be left alone to do
things the way we want to do them and
the second thing is that this edifice of
regulatory the regulatory state depends
absolutely on us voluntarily complying
with it and that I think that with the
private
resources the private wealth that is out
there I'm not talking about random civil
disobedience I'm talking about using
private resources to stand up to the
regulatory state through sort of
systemic civil disobedience and in
de-facto nullifying large chunks of the
regulatory state because the government
realizes it can no longer enforce them
I'll just leave that as a teaser I have
yet to work out the details but I'm
gonna start yes we had a question back
here there somebody had a hand up there
there we are I agree with everything
that you that you stated my concern and
what I've been studying is looking at
the students side of the story rather
than the parents and the upbringing they
come from I'm from California California
as you mentioned is different although
we add all Californians at this table so
we're okay how when you say that that
the the uppers are going to continue are
you assuming that their children will
just kind of mush in and slip into their
shoes or will we as educators be able to
change that pattern if we become more
aware of what is happening and we teach
that way the last statistic I read was
something like 60 to 65 percent of the
graduates from colleges in the cross the
United States today are not going into
jobs that are pertinent to the degree
that they hold well there are a whole
bunch of things in your and your
question there that I could talk about
let me just focus on a couple one of the
things that happens when you have this
college sorting machine that I talked
about is that you have what's called
homogamy education on monogamy but you
also have cognitive homogamy and so
before if you were really successful
and let's say CEO in your 30s who are
you married to you were married to the
girl next door because you've probably
got married at age of 20 or or if you
got married later you married a girl at
the Country Club who's not also so she's
not selected for IQ necessarily however
if you're getting married if you know if
you're a CEO and your 30s now in a male
who are you married to probably you
didn't get married until 28 29 or 30 or
maybe after that who did you marry you
married this Yale lawyer who was
litigating a correct case against your
company and you thought she was really
cute and and so what happens is and this
happens on a very large scale that you
have really smart people marry and it's
smart not just smart but industrious and
hard-working and all sorts of other
personality characteristics they're
marrying each other and they are
producing some really sensational kids
in many cases sensational in terms of
their talents there is one other aspect
of them which is I think many of them
are hothouse flowers I'm not sure what
their degree of resilience is but but
there's an awful lot of talent there so
in many ways there is an argument to be
made that the new upper class has a
cross-generational tenacity that it did
not have before that shirt sleeves the
shirt sleeves in three generations
doesn't apply as much now as it used to
and that makes me a little pessimistic
the other your other remarks about
college and not and having jobs that
have nothing to do with our college to
read don't get me started I mean I am a
guy who published op eds after a book
that I wrote about education op-eds
entitled the BA is the work of the devil
so I have a lot to say on that that I
will not get into
you know you were talking about the old
popular culture approximately a hundred
thousand in the new upper class narrow
narrowly defined hi I work in live on
the west side of Hollywood and I think
there's a couple of hundred thousand
personal opinion perhaps you comment on
that and I think the culture isn't lower
than you allude to I think that culture
is lower than you loo to did you hear me
before yeah I could hear you this okay
good good that I won't repeat that and
it's sort of a two-part question the
late Steve Jobs was he a genius an
entrepreneur or just a plain good
businessman thank you I hate being asked
questions that I'm not competent to
answer um first place with a hundred
thousand I was referring how many people
are there whose decisions affect the
national culture politics and economy
and that's a pretty small number with
somebody like Steve Jobs I think the
answer is yes one of the one of the
things about n was by the way though
that he wasn't nearly as good as his 20s
as he was in his 40s when he came back
to Apple at the age of in his early
forties he was a brilliant CEO whereas
he'd been pretty far off the edge when
he in his first incarnation at Apple we
have one down in front I will take that
one back there and then come down front
thank you for your talk I'm a teacher in
San Diego I'm also a congressional
candidate I make less than 50,000 a year
I've grown up with the advantages that
you've mentioned as advantageous such as
mixing with different parts of the
culture I have that in my background is
that a good background for a Republican
for a conservative to have running for
office nowadays perfect it's the
absolutely perfect background of I'll
tell you well you invited me to
pontificate about the Republican Party
if there are millions of people out
there who vote Democratic usually who I
think would vote for a Republican
candidate with your kind of background
who is Foursquare no-holds-barred in
favor of freedom opportunity and free
enterprise the Republican Party has
gotten a reputation of being first you
have a whole bunch of fat cats Wall
Street guys collusive capitalists I mean
by collusive capitalist I mean partly
crony capitalism but also all of these
business firms which are in bed with the
regulatory agencies and are perfectly
happy to have regulations that favor
them and the disadvantage smaller
competition that that's one set of
Republicans that are in the public mind
and the other are social conservatives
and and I say this respectfully of those
of you with socially conservative views
but who who a great many people are not
going to vote for you any candidate who
holds them just because of the cultural
wars and so forth I think there is a
there are common themes that could not
unite a great many Americans and that
the precisely the right spokesman
spokesperson for those kinds of views
are someone with your background good
luck to you and we're going to come down
front here yes my name is David stringer
from Prescott Arizona dr. Murray you are
perhaps best known for a book written in
1994 I believe called the bell curve
which argued and I'm oversimplifying
that basically there are significant
meaningful and enduring differences
between racial groups and IQ achievement
and I'm just wondering if you could
comment about given the changing
demographics of our country
what does that portend for our future
you correctly stated what the bell curve
said as described by the people
who reviewed the book who had not read
it the the subtitle of the book was
intelligence and class structure in
American life those two great themes I
talked about during my speech the
increasing value of brains in the
marketplace and the college sorting
machine that's the book and in writing
the book we had a chapter on racial
differences because if you're going to
generalize this you have to address all
the questions that are ordinarily raised
about cultural bias and the test than IQ
doesn't really mean anything in the rest
of that race was a trivial issue in the
book there has been nothing that's
happened since then that makes me think
it is any more important than I thought
it was then and so the answer is no
there's there's nothing about the
dimensions and demographics or anything
else that have much of effect on
anything but I'm really glad you gave me
a chance to reveal what the bell curve
was actually about and if any of you
doubt it you can still get copies in
Amazon and you can check it out for
yourself go down here
Hey hang on for just a second that
microphone is on its way
I'm just curious that nothing was said
about the other class in our country and
that is all the government unionized
workers that have created a special
class for themselves
I think that's causing a great cancer
only way our government works I
essentially agree with that and and I
think that probably some of the most
pernicious effects there are felt not at
the federal level they are felt at the
local level I mean the the the union
contracts that are negotiated by city
you know come on and to negotiate a
contract you've got to have somebody who
has some skin in the game and when you
have a mayor negotiating with the labor
union it's not his money that he's
giving up over he when he negotiates
these contracts and it has made it
really difficult to provide basic kinds
of public services that shouldn't cost
nearly as much money as they cost and
California I think is Exhibit A because
you have leads I think you've been at
the cutting edge as California so often
is in this time in terms of bankruptcies
of
large cities because of the kinds of
things you're talking about the
difficulty is that well it's going to be
very interesting we now have the example
of California and the problems that it
is created because of in some part
because of the problem you described we
have other states like Indiana and
elsewhere where they have a not had
nearly as much at many of those problems
are we going to have a sort of common
sense reaction by the other states
saying we want to go the way Indiana
went we don't want to go the way
California when we are going to find out
this will be our final question okay and
we have a hand-up down okay and worry
about that this is the final question
thank you
you hit pretty close to home when you
mentioned when that kill annoying
because that's where it came from and in
my day Don Rumsfeld was one of my
classmates in high school and his
parents and my parents were lifelong
friends we went to New Trier High School
following us were people like John
Stossel
who you currently see on Fox News but
also Cook County Illinois Chicago to be
precise Rahm Emanuel also a New Trier
High School no kid Edgewood yes didn't
know that yes sir I I recognize that
this is a unique question perhaps but
Mike what Irie concerned about is what
we stood for back in the 1940s and 50s
has now totally deteriorated into what
passes for progressive liberals today
and I'm my question to you is can we
resolve this can we overcome this can we
but what is the solution how do we
reclaim the United States the the
freedom the the Constitution the the
where we're free to live our own lives
as we see fit as long as we don't
interfere with somebody else's life when
we're up against this seemingly
screaming progressive group that won't
even let us get a word in edgewise
because they always out shot us we try
to debate and they out shout so I would
be very interested in the solution that
you see as to how we we come back how we
may reclaim our country Anita you went
one question too long
look um here here is the reality the
people in this room including me we
actually do pretty much live our lives
as we see fit yes the government gets in
our way in certain respects we pay too
much in taxes we have to go to the DMV
to get our driver's licenses but with
more serious problems if we have a
company we probably have lawyers that
can deal with a lot of the government
nonsense and if in our private lives we
do have resources that we can we we
actually de facto live pretty free lives
most of us the people who don't are the
people much further down the
socio-economic ladder are in the middle
class and in the lower working class for
whom the kinds of depredations that the
the current state puts on really does
prevent them in all sorts of ways not
just from living their lives as they see
fit in terms of work but have had
enormous effects on on their incentives
to form families on the way their
communities operate I think that the
reclaiming has to proceed as follows
those of us who still enjoy the fruits
of freedom have to become advocates for
those who do not do not enjoy those that
we are not taking these positions so
that we can get a 5% cut in our marginal
tax rate that we are taking these
positions because freedom is not just a
right freedom is expedient in living a
satisfying life and that we are
currently depriving our fellow Americans
of doing that it is wrong and the reason
that we are going to make these changes
is not to enrich ourselves but to enrich
our fellow citizens once we can start to
make that case we have a chance of
winning the argument as long as it is
seen a bit as an argument between the
compassion
people and the selfish people we're
going to lose but we can change the
debate because what I just said about
freedom is the truth thank you very much